[Music]
autism is both a devastating problem and
it's still a puzzle largely what causes
what he's been causing the dramatic
increase in the in the in the prevalence
of this of this disease in the last 40
years or so so it's almost like an
exponential increase part of that is
really due to better diagnosis and the
diagnostic criteria but a lot of people
think that something in our environment
has played a role in in causing this
increase and it's worldwide it's not
just in North America it's in Asia it's
in Europe so something environmental the
the genes the genetic risk factors for
autism have obviously always been there
and but something else must have
triggered and so you know some people
think it's it's something in a diet it
and and that is possible it could also
be something in what we do to our gut
microbes so the use of antibiotics the
the obsession with keeping things more
and more sterile from from the day we
were born you know throughout our
lifetime so people have thought about to
set potentially a change in a microbial
composition diversity inside of us are
our positives
now there's many observations that link
the brain and the gut in in autism
clinically the majority of autistic
children have have digestive problems
constipation abdominal pain discomfort
part of that is most likely due to the
diet the unique diet that autistic
children self-select force many things
are excluded from a diet that we
normally would like fiber fermented
foods and so it's it's quite possible
that that plays a role
and there are people that have thought
about this why do kids select such a
diet seems to have to do a lot with the
texture of foods so their unique
disturbance in the sensitivity for the
texture not so much for the content so
things that are soft and are much
preferred over crunchy and and and chewy
things and then you know people have
started to look at the microbial
composition so they looked at the gut
microbes in fecal samples from from
patients with autism and have found
abnormalities the problem is most of
those studies are small they're often
not well controlled they we now
understand that autism is a spectrum
autism spectrum disorder and it probably
contains several different subsets of
patients so if you just take a small
number of patients measure their they
got microbes it's you're likely to pick
up variable patterns because you it's
not a homogeneous group of patients now
the last thing that's happened which has
really thrown a lot of attention to it
has been a study published a couple
years ago by a group at Caltech in in in
California which showed that in an
animal model of what's called maternal
immune activation so what the mother
undergoes and an infection or immune
activation during pregnancy and then the
offspring the mouse offspring shows
altered social behavior and there's
various tests that have been taken as as
animal behavior equivalents to to human
autism always you know a big jump from
something from from animal behaviors to
something as complex as all the
disturbances in autism but that has
received a lot of attention because in
these animals that have this behavior
they have an altered gut microbial
composition produced different
metabolites particularly
one metabolite that's also been found in
human patients and they have a leaky gut
so they have immune activation in the
gut and by treating these animals with
that's sort of most intriguing by
treating them with a probiotic which is
called B fragilis the investigators were
able to reverse many of those
behavioural changes and the gut
abnormalities in these in these mice so
this has triggered a tremendous interest
now there's efforts underway to produce
this probiotic and make it acceptable
for human use so it's not a probiotic
that you currently can get in your
yogurt or cheese it has to be approved
has to be cultured and but clinical
trials will happen the next couple of
years that there will test this
hypothesis can you actually by
influencing the microbial composition
reverse some of the changes either in
terms of the gut dysfunction or
cognitive and social interaction of
these patients one would assume that in
humans the earlier you could start their
therapy after delivery and this is
clearly a developmental disorder that
starts initially almost with
imperceptible changes in the newborn and
then gradually becomes clinically
obvious the earlier you could start this
treatment the more likely it would be it
would be beneficial so autism in many
ways is the prototypic brain gut
microbiome disorder so this model is
almost certainly gonna lead to a better
understanding and breakthroughs and
diagnosis and therapy but we're still
they're still a ways to go so probiotic
is is a microbe with a demonstrated
health benefit so lots of microbes would
qualify for this I mean
100 trillion of these microbes inside of
our gut so many of those are potential
probiotics that if you isolate them
culture them and then give them to
humans that would be and that's like
with with this beef fragile is it's it's
produced in the in the context of of
infections and abscesses strangely but
but it has been shown to have many
beneficial effects also stimulating the
immune system that effect on autism
appears to be different from the one
that has been demonstrated earlier from
its anti-inflammatory effect on on the
gods immune system so it's it does exist
it just doesn't exist in a form that is
currently less commercially available or
that is would be allowed by the by the
FDA that you could put this into humans
so that the trials will have to
demonstrate the safety which most likely
you know will be shown but the FDA is
fairly strict any time you use a
probiotic even the ones that are in
commercially available products if you
want to do if you want to prove that you
know a particular yogurt is with its
microbes its probiotics is beneficial
for a disease condition you need to get
FDA approval just like for any other
drug which is complex a complex process
time-consuming process and this has kind
of slowed the the progress in this field
of identifying microbes with potential
health so new the new microbes has
potential health benefits
[Music]